pour yourself a parsley soda because
season 2 of a series of unfortunate
events is an entertaining ly dark ride
that's positively jam-packed with Easter
eggs yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan
here and today I'm going to run through
some very cool things you might have
missed in the new series including
references cameos and connections to TV
shows movies and the original books
obviously spoilers ahead if you're not
up-to-date with season 2 at the start of
the first episode mr. Poe mentions how
he simply can't put down a book called
the pony party which if you look at the
jacket seems to be the first in a series
of cheerful stories about the luckiest
kids in the world written by Loney m/sec
Nick however in reality there is no pony
party book it's just a reversible cover
for hardback editions of Lemony Snicket
the unauthorized autobiography and pony
party author Loney and set nick is an
anagram of Lemony Snicket if you've read
the original books you'll know that
Olivia Caliban is a rather different
character in the TV series in the novel
she only appears in the ninth book the
carnivorous carnival where she's known
as a fortune-teller Madame Lulu and she
turns out to be the person who's been
giving Count Olaf information on where
he can find the Baudelaire orphans each
time they escaped from him and she's the
one who reveals to Olaf that Beverly
Elliot and Shabbo are actually violet
Klaus and sunny
however in the TV show Olivia Caliban
pops up at the start of season two in
the austere Academy episodes where she's
a librarian who later joins up with
Jacques thicket to try and help the Bois
de leurs and later again she takes on
the alias of fortune-teller Madame Lulu
which is a rotating position for any VFD
agent staying at the carnival
by the way the Caligari carnival and
Madame Lulu's Caligari cabinets get
their names from a silent horror movie
called the cabinet of dr. Caligari as
mr. Poe drives the Baudelaires to their
next guardians in the village of foul
devotees he talks to them about count
Omar which you might think was just a
slip of the tongue thanks to the
constant coverage of my wife's newspaper
I'm sure that count Omar will be
captured in no time at all oh yes I
meant to say homework besides however in
the seventh book the vile village the
daily poke teleo newspaper gets counter
name wrong calling him count omar which
leads the people living in the village
of foul devotees to repeatedly refer to
Count Olaf as count Omar much to the
frustration of the Baudelaires
although the VFD villagers and the TV
series don't do this mr. Polk does refer
to count Omar a couple of times in part
1 and part 2 of the vile village that's
but you of all people know that count
Omar was far from innocent Count Olaf
yes see who named it gives the shivers
that bushy eyebrow the tattoo of that
eye on his ankle and the daily ponte leo
also gets Olaf's name wrong in several
articles in part 2 of the earth sat
elevator there's a clever call back when
to gain access to the inn auction
Jacqueline recycles the trick that Count
Olaf played on her in the first season
by using the fake name he made up to get
an appointment with mr. Poe I have an
appointment name haircut haircut yes
Zuka haircut is my name yes I got
haircut yes yes
this is Larry your waiter did you get
past the bouncer but he has to let me in
I'm on the list
yes haircut when Lemony Snicket is in
the tunnels there's a sign for de new
mom which is a nod to the hotel de new
mall the main location of the 12th book
the penultimate peril which will be part
of season 3 the sign is also reference
to triplets ernest frank and pewter
newell you own that hotel and the word
de Newmont is a literary term meaning
the final part of a film play or story
that brings together strands of the plot
also when Klaus and violet are searching
for the Snicket files at Heimlich
Hospital there's a file labeled slippery
slopes which is a nod to the 10th book
the slippery slope which will be adapted
in the first episodes of season 3 of
course at the end of season 2 the Bois
de leurs also literally find themselves
on a slippery slope there's a lovely
meta moment in episode 9 when Neil
Patrick Harris drops of reference to his
previous big TV show How I Met Your
Mother which ran for nine seasons and
was set in New York City if she's so
good at fortune-telling why does she
live out here in the hinterlands instead
of having her own television show in the
city I tried that for nine years look
we're done
on top of that season one featured
Harris's How I Met Your Mother co-star
Cobie Smulders playing the quagmire
children's mother and season two brings
another reunion for Harrison a former
co-star when Olaf confronts Nathan
Fillion Jacques Snicket in the village
of fowl devotees Harrison Fillion
previously worked together in dr.
Horrible's sing-along blog where harris
played an aspiring supervillain to
Fillion superhero Captain Hammer and
they're not the only shows that Neil
Patrick Harris wants starred in they get
a hat tip this season in episode 8 when
Count Olaf meets Doctor Faustus who's
actually Klaus in disguise Olaf tells
Faustus that he looks terribly young to
be a doctor which is funny because as a
young actor Harris's breakthrough role
was playing a teen genius doctor in the
comedy drama Doogie Howser MD which ran
from 1989 to 1993 oh and by the way the
name Doctor Faustus is a literary
reference for 16th century English play
about a man who makes a deal with the
devil as my squalor gets to worse some
pretty memorable outfits in the series
including one that seems to draw
inspiration from the villainous Cruella
De Vil and later when Emma tells Madame
Lulu that she was forced to make her own
dress with few scraps of tent and then
the camera reveals holes cut out of a
tent it's reminiscent of Disney's
Enchanted where she's L made herself a
dress out of a set of curtains leaving
an outline visible in the remaining
material now you might think that's a
stretch but enchanted was produced by
barry sonnenfeld and he's the showrunner
for a series of unfortunate events
indeed barry sonnenfeld also pops up
several times in the show including in a
cameo as aren't Josephine's husband i
can't whistle on a poster for barry the
pinhead at the Caligari carnival and he
also provides the voice of mr. Tom
Elaine during mr. Poe's phone
conversation about the pony party oh yes
the bull ears and speaking of cameos
Neil Patrick Harris his real-life
husband David Burtka plays a rather
vocal audience member during the
carnivorous carnival episodes and
they're joined in the season finale by
their actual children Harper and Gideon
the makers of a series of unfortunate
events are obviously big fans of
director Stanley Kubrick's The Shining
because they already included and nods
the famous horror movie in season one
here shammy and they pay tribute to it
again not once but twice in season two
in part one of the hostile Hospital
Administrative Babs is wandering the
hospital's corridors in the dark when
she's frightened by the two identically
dressed white faced women who suddenly
appear ahead of her saying hello Babs
come and play with us this scene is a
clear hat tip to the Grady sisters in
the shining who appeared to young Danni
asking him to come and play with them as
he's cycling along the hotel's corridors
in the second part of the burglars story
at the heimlich hospital the hench
person of indeterminate gender smashes
down the door to a room where violet
Klaus and Sonia hiding
Here I am nurse Luke upon which is a
parody of Jack Nicholson's famous line
here's Johnny
now what were your favourite Easter eggs
and moments in the show and what are you
most looking forward to in season 3 I
can't wait to read your comments below
you can also tweet me at Jan underscore
Gilbert and at flake City
remember to like subscribe and turn on
your notifications if you enjoyed this
video and you can click here for more
videos your life including my season 1
unfortunate events Easter eggs thanks
for watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers